high level question
what do you think it takes to build a uh
system with
superhuman maybe let's say human level
or superhuman level
general intelligence we've already kind
of started talking about this but
what's your intuition like does this
thing have to have a body
does it does it have to interact richly
with the world
uh does it have to have some more human
elements like
self-awareness i think emotion
i think emotion is something which is
like it's not really attributed
typically in standard machine learning
it's not something we think about like
there is nlp there is vision there is no
like emotion
emotion is never a part of all of this
and that just seems a little bit weird
to me
i think the reason basically being that
there is surprise
and like basically emotion is like one
of the reasons emotions arise is like
what happens and what you expect to
happen right there is like a mismatch
between these things
and so that gives rise like i can either
be surprised
i can be saddened or i can be happy and
all of this and so
this basically indicates that i already
have a predictive model in my head
and something that i predicted or
something that i thought was likely to
happen
and then there was something that i
observed that happened that there was a
disconnect between these two things
and that basically is like maybe one of
the reasons i like
you have a lot of emotions yeah i i
think so i talk to people a lot about
him
like uh lisa feldman barrett i think
that's an interesting conceptual emotion
but
i have a sense that emotion primarily
in the way we think about it which is
the display of emotion
is a communication mechanism between
humans
so it's a part of basically human to
human interaction
uh an important part but just the part
so it's like
it i would throw it into the um
into the full mix of communication
and to me communication can be done with
objects that
don't look at all like humans okay
i've seen our ability to
anthropomorphize our ability to connect
with things that look like a roomba
our ability to connect first of all
let's talk about other biological
systems like dogs
our ability to love things that are very
different than humans
but they do display emotion right i mean
dogs do display
emotions so they don't have to be
anthropomorphic for them to
like display the kind of emotion that we
don't want exactly so emo
i mean but then the the word emotion
starts to lose um
so then we have to be i guess specific
but yeah so have rich
flavorful communication communication
yeah yeah so like it
yes it's full of emotion it's full of uh
wit and humor and uh
moods and all those kinds of things yeah
so exactly so
you're talking about like flavor flavor
yeah okay
so there's content and then there is
flavor and i'm talking about the flavor
do you think he needs to have a body do
you think like to interact with the
physical world do you think you can
understand the physical world without
being able to directly interact with it
i don't think so yeah i think at some
point we will need to bite the bullet
and actually interact with the physical
as much as i like working on like
passive computer vision where i just
like sit in my armchair and look at
videos and learn
i do think that uh we will need to have
some kind of embodiment
or some kind of interaction uh to figure
out things about the world
what about consciousness do you think
you think
how often do you think about
consciousness when you think about your
work
you could think of as the more simple
thing of self-awareness
yeah of of being aware that you are
a uh perceiving sensing
acting thing in this world or you can
think about the
bigger thing version of that which is
consciousness which is uh having
it feel like something to be that entity
the subjective experience of being in
this world so i think of self-awareness
a little bit more than this like the
broader goal of it because
i think self-awareness is pretty
critical for like any kind of
like any kind of agi or whatever you
want to call it that field build because
it needs to contextualize what it is and
what role
is playing with respect to all the other
things that exist around it
i think that requires self-awareness it
needs to understand
that it's an autonomous car right and
what does that mean
what are its limitations what are the
things that it is supposed to do and so
on what is its role in some way
or i mean so i mean this is these are
the kind of things that we
kind of expect from it i would say and
so
that's the level of self-awareness
that's i would say basically required at
least
if not more than that yeah i tend to on
the emotion side believe that it has to
have
it has to be able to display
consciousness
display consciousness what do you mean
by that meaning like for us humans to
connect with each other
or to connect with other living entities
i think we need to feel like in order
for us to uh
truly feel like that there's another
being there
we have to believe that they're
conscious and so
we won't ever connect with something
that doesn't
have elements of consciousness now i
tend to think
that that's easier to achieve than it
may sound
because we anthropomorphized stuff so
hard like
you have a mug that just like has wheels
and like rotates
every once in a while and makes a sound
i think uh
a couple days in especially if you're uh
if you're if you don't hang out with
humans you might start to believe that
mug on wheels is conscious so
i think we anthropomorphized pretty
effectively as human beings
but i do think that it's it's in the
same bucket that we'll call emotion
that show that uh
you're you know i think of consciousness
as the capacity to suffer
and if you're an entity that's able to
feel
things in the world and to communicate
that to others
i think that's a really powerful way to
interact with humans
and in order to create an agi system i
believe
you should be able to richly interact
with humans
like humans would need to want to
interact with you
like it can't be like it's it's the um
self-supervised learning versus like uh
like
the robot shouldn't have to pay you to
interact with me
so like it should be a natural fun thing
and then you're going to
scale up significantly how much
interaction it gets
it's the elect surprise which they're
trying to get me to be a judge
on their uh contest let's see if i want
to do that
but their their challenge is to uh
talk to you make the judge make the
human
sufficiently interested that the human
keeps talking for 20 minutes
to alexa to alexa yeah and right now
they're not even close to that because
it just gets so boring when you're like
when the intelligence is not there it
gets very not interesting to talk to it
and so the robot needs to be interesting
and one of the ways it can be
interesting
is display the capacity to to love
to suffer and i i would say that
essentially means
the the capacity to display
consciousness
like it is an entity much like a human
being
of course what that really means i don't
know if that's fundamentally a robotics
problem or
some kind of problem that we're not yet
even aware like if it is truly a hard
problem of consciousness
i tend to maybe optimistically think
it's a um
we can pretty effectively fake it till
we make it so we can display
a lot of human-like elements for a while
and
that will be sufficient to form really
close connections with humans
you